all right good morning thank you for
investing your time coming here I will
start off by saying that it's great to
see you and also that it's great to be a
one out of three speakers beginning this
great event I think this is a wonderful
community everybody comes with a giving
attitude and it really makes makes this
a great conference in a great place and
I wanted to you know thank the
organizers and celebrate that before I
start so my name is yeah maybe to start
with some ideas for today to set the
attitude get ready to experiment we will
move quickly we have a lot to cover but
my assumption is that and I can see all
of you are very focused and you've spent
years and years educating yourselves so
my idea for this talk is to for us to
try to gather as many things as we can
so that you feel the ownership of these
new skills or perhaps you already know
these skills but use them in a new
setting so that you have like a seed
planted in your in your mind and then
you when you go home and you read about
it it's something that you can relate to
that you've already tried this is the
idea so don't don't feel don't be
worried if if if we were moving fast or
if it you know if something is not a
completely clear from the outset just go
with it try it try first ask questions
later study later these things are not
too difficult and the purpose is to
learn to I mean to either learn how to
cultivate your ability to ship because
that's in the end that's what matters
and yeah please make friends with those
around you please connect and
collaborate and this is also going to
bring more value for you from from this
time
lots of like-minded brilliant people
here so take advantage of that it's a
special set of three days
okay so my name's me.how or I come from
Poland and that's how that's our
heritage of the name Michael and so you
can call me Michael me how it's how you
spell it
I've been a data science consultant and
the science data engineering also a bit
of software engineering and
orchestrating services started out in
the academic environment there's a
mobile phone data research like
discovering like patterns of
transportation and yeah the the
different kinds of behavior and modeling
it and understanding what's going on
there smart meter data as well I've
moved on to commercial consulting and
have been living well since then I'm a
husband and a dad as well I feel like I
need to say it because otherwise you're
gonna think who is this high school kid
talking to you it's child prodigy
advising investment banks no I took my
time to learn stuff so I just kept a
youthful appearance jokes aside yeah I
the human part of me is here as well I
like these things and more and it's a
pleasure to meet you I look forward to
speaking if you have time later to catch
up it will be great to meet you and
moving on from there back to the Welcome
slide yeah I really feel that you know
the things you can learn are changing so
quickly like a few years ago who heard
of you know pi torch and 2015 or
kubernetes in 2015-16 and these days are
they're being so widely used so it seems
that you know spending years in a
university learning things is great it's
still very wonderful but there's a need
to acquire specialized knowledge quickly
and and also with that comes the
conundrum of validating your credentials
so how do you learn things quickly in a
specialized way there's businesses
coming up that solve that like the
lambda school for example but there's
also like how do I show my diploma from
that and my thesis here is that
your portfolio is your diploma
so hence why my motivation to - let us
try stuff and really yeah move quickly
try a lot of things and get you to ship
your stuff and like I'm sure many of you
are experts and contributing things to
your businesses to open source and still
like I feel like that sharpening the
edge and becoming better at shipping
designing solutions that not only come
from the you know analytical genius but
also like let people use what you have
that that that makes a huge difference
so yeah just to encourage you to do as
much as you can and not pay too much
attention if if something doesn't make
complete sense now you can you know
watch the video again do it at home
again yeah okay so these are the
high-level steps we have a lot to cover
we're going to make an end to end
situation starting with consuming data
from a live service we're gonna use
reddit and here a disclaimer if you see
any messages that offend you I'm sorry
this is read it
I wish there wasn't messages that offend
you or that you weren't offended by them
but yeah we're dealing with live data
and I think it's part of the benefit but
also has has some drawbacks then we're
going to learn how to launch and
integrate a message queue service really
quickly the prototype our solution and
enable us to separate the different
roles and cultivate this mindset of like
designing a system of elements rather
than one you know giant stepwise
solution in one by file or notebook then
we're going to subscribe and do some
pre-processing of the text serve a
machine learning model for NLP
and then publish this to the messaging
app which in this case is telegram
telegram is very easy to set up for
development it also has some encryption
features if you're interested in that
for me the the richness of the API is
what has drawn me to use it and to
propose it but hopefully you'll be able
to experiment the other BOTS as well and
also keep you know keep your ideas as
you see potential ways of improving this
prototype
please note them down please have them
ready and and make them part of your
plan for how to enhance something that
you would like because I want you to
leave this room with a system that you
have a plan of improving and you can
make your own you can make it do
something for you that you care about
like for example I don't see what stocks
people talk about and why and be
notified just so you can like try and
invest in things that you know I don't
know just another stream or yeah
whatever you follow Twitter for some
reason and you have some piece of
information that you want to extract
from there and be notified in a special
way that Twitter doesn't serve or any
other thing so I want you to have your
ideas write them down and make it really
active because like I think studying and
learning and improving is an active
process and yeah I just want to put that
you know it's Park make it make it more
may your your enthusiasm and in
initiative to come here is it's
wonderful and you know let's keep the
momentum so finally we'll organize that
into a bunch of services that work
together and are easily servable so
you'll be able to start the whole
orchestra with one command thanks to dr.
Campos okay so like I said let's just
move quickly and I'll try to fit in some
time for questions I hope you have had a
chance to look at the requirements file
so this is it just to verify may be
quickly oh I also wanted to ask so who
here feels that their advance and this
is like more interesting to them rather
than lots of new things I want to know
who who feels that you know they're they
own this space already can you raise
your hand can I get a shorthand
don't be too humble I just wanted to say
that I'm not assuming that you don't
know any of these things but at every
session or at every I mean maybe even
one conference you'll get one or two
things main things that you'll take away
you'll probably not have a million
things you just it's it's you know that
one thing that you can take to your work
or take to your business and make a
difference so be on the lookout for that
one thing even if you're an expert I
hope you'll take at least you know one
interesting thing and that will ya
basically elevate your how fast you move
forward and makes it make life easier
for you cool so that that aside who has
done the steps the prep steps excellent
so those notice who raised your raise
your hand around you and like if you're
in trouble go and ask them otherwise I
there will be the so if you saw the git
repo has directories that are steps so
if you want I can like push the steps as
they are being fulfilled so that you can
like forget the past step if it didn't
work and move forward so essential is
and I called a Python and the repo and
then hopefully had the environment yeah
kondeh environments super important
there's a lot to be said about Conda
it's it's really good as you know as a
package to deliver especially if you
work for corporations it's easier to
convince executives to like get one
license for one thing and approve one
thing rather than approve 50 different
modules but for us like the users of
this technology I still remember that
long summer afternoon when I hadn't know
it was that probably was i remember the
season but in 2015-16 i tried to use
cafe you know this neural network
framework and i spent so much time
installing dependencies and different
binaries and I also had I was trying to
install them natively on the MA
can the Mac just like this allowed
relative paths and for security and in
the end I spend so much time configuring
the environment rather than trying out
the framework and like I think this is
where condi really shines it installs
binaries even of things that are outside
of the Python world without the need for
building it so if you like want to
download one of the dependencies with
Jason net and for some of you didn't
install I heard but Jason that as a
dependency of allen and LP which is this
great framework for this for building
like using deep learning for LP and yeah
if you install with pip it will like
mumble that you need to kind of have
this compiler or that thing and fail
building and every little thing that
delays action will basically yeah take
your time away from what you want to do
so it also makes like telling others
what dependencies are needed easier so I
hope you noticed those benefits and I
want to encourage you to use content
varmints okay so step one will be to
build the consumer so if you have the
repository checked out if you know if
you navigate there in command line and
start Jupiter lab or or rather let me do
it first zoom in that's one giant window
is that visible let me do even more okay
so
I want to do kondeh activate NLP
workshop which is the name of this
environment okay you can see by the name
here that it's activated and I would
like to now start Jupiter lab who is
familiar and who is using Jupiter lab
there we go not this browser can I get a
show of hands
Jupiter lab users okay great so I was
expecting more of us but that's fine
that means more of us can learn about it
so Jupiter lab what it is is it's a
basically a very powerful innovation
that takes console interactivity to the
next level by maintaining the history
and basically lets you tell a story with
both code and explanation and
visualization and data and it's
excellent for prototyping for telling
stories some people even use it like
just as code files and launch it and
launch them so we're going to use it now
here we're going to zoom in and we have
our so there is a jupiter notebook which
is the classical you can see it when you
go to tree and then you have like one
notebook per page and lab appeared
around version five of ipython i believe
and what lab does it gives you the power
of foss4g yes multiple different windows
that you can create so let's go here to
step one consumer in cue and open bra
bra surprise the reddit API which we'll
be using and I hope you have got your
API keys if you don't have them please
get them it's really
easy quick follow the link in the readme
you will need to to go so the beauty of
Jupiter lab have a look I I just went
back to the launcher and launch terminal
and I have like pro and terminal side by
side so I'll go to terminal and do LS
yeah and you can see I have this dot end
file which is where I can keep my
environment variables I can have dot n
listed in get ignore and I will avoid
the fallacy of committing my security
credentials into version control which
always one person in the project does so
don't be that person and a helper for
that is Python end which then gets
imported as don't end it loads from that
file and populates the environment
variables so boom I have it loaded now
and I can start the consumer I can get n
and get my wave ID ready it's secret and
come up with the user agent okay and it
and then I have actually I have my
reddit consumer and now I want to
connect to a subreddit and consume
comments as they appear live so I
invoked consumer that subreddit and I am
taking amusing stalks
another one that's safe to use this
suggest me a book books aren't
aggressive or political and some of them
are but like it's still a book and I
want this to avoid the heated political
topics and still have the benefit of
consuming a live source so now what we
want to do is just get some messages so
let's say the way to do that we can set
up a stream and we can say for comment
and sub reddit stream coming
print Oh and break I want to break
because I want to just see one come and
see what it looks like okay you can see
I'm just getting the ID so what I want
to do here is I probably want to do more
and I've prepared a helper method in the
extract so what I can do I can from
extract which is here in the local
directory I can import and what can I
import I can import extract post or
extract comment there really has
different streaming for comments and for
submissions so we're gonna use comments
if you want just swap this for
submissions and swap this for extract
post but I'm going to import and now I'm
going to do extract comment wait for one
to come okay yep hold how to make money
in stocks someone is talking about a
book and we can see this the created UTC
so the time stamp the text the ID
uploads and after we're going to stick
with text and what we want to do now is
we want to start our system so let's
let's have this consumer get messages
extract them put them on a on the queue
and we'll figure out what happens next
in the next chapter because we want to
isolate this idea the the benefit of
that will be maybe even have it in a
slide but I'm going to tell you anyway
no I don't is we can then have one time
one download and plug-in many services
to consume that it's one of the benefits
another is some person can is some over
teammates or ourselves can work on it in
isolation cool so moving forward let's
speed up so another helper from I mean
it's just to import MQ which is some
helper functions for a message going
which in this case is
just putting it down there and let's
also import oh no let's let's yeah let's
do that
I'm Q so the reason we use that is it's
a J it's an object that we want to
serialize it to Jason but that that
makes me remember that what we want to
do now is we going to open Redis ipy and
be the other notebook and here yeah you
know if you want to use a solution for
storing data or you want to you know
connect to something again you don't
want to waste time setting it up and you
want it reusable you want it easy to set
up you want you know you want your
friends to use it as well so what do you
want what we're going to use here is
just instead of installing read is
configuring it setting up a path and and
so forth we're just going to download a
docker which contains an image of a
machine that has just Redis and serves
it so will that it's very easy there
were way we do it is we just say what
message what image we want to use Redis
on alpine Linux which is the super low
weight weight Linux name the container
like so map the port and it's going to
map to our localhost so there we go I
just now I have Redis and I can it's
running and I can connect to it so now
I'm going back to my other notebook and
I can import Redis which is a Python
module called R equals Redis thought it
is I don't need to specify any
parameters I'm gonna use defaults and it
connected if I hadn't had the docker on
it would tell me there's no red is there
and now my MS MSG is this then I can
print msg let's say MQ serialized
message data msg it's this print one
there we go it's just
extra you know wrapping its Jason
now it's Jason it's a string it can go
on the pipe and what we do next is we
let's also import TQ DM which is this
fantastic progress bar solution and just
wrap this around so we know how many
comments went through and then r dot
publish Redis publish to the comments
and then MSG and let's just run it okay
we've got one it's gonna keep populating
but there we go we have a have a service
going okay we had a have a hundred so it
actually pulls a hundred the first time
you launch it and then it
that's your rate and then you're going
to get them as they come so let me just
go back to here we've moved on this nice
and clean we didn't have to spend any
time configuring it which is great
and we got all the benefit which is even
better and then I think I talked about
this important idea to modularize things
that makes it a system instead of having
one PI file with many functions or
multiple PI file files we have like
something that can be chunked and tested
separately makes it easier to
orchestrate removes duplication of use
and easier to work on it as a team
so let's move to step two we'll go back
to the lab click the little home click
step to open the consumer so I'm having
a bunch of small consoles here I'm going
to import Redis again use pub/sub
subscribe to comments
going to import mq and let's get one
message
so that now what I need to do is I need
to wait for a message to come but at
that end I to avoid having to wait I
have I have created a helper pipe test
message so I can just invoke it iPhone
write this message with many O's and you
can see it came through so we don't have
to wait for the messages to come we can
test our system but some messages will
come anyway actually they are coming
still we can see there may be we're
sharing the Wi-Fi distributed
denial-of-service okay
and what we want to do now is we want to
do some basic cleaning there should be
extensive cleaning so if you have ideas
write them down think about how you
enhance it but for now let's use the
some of the things I prepared there's
some things here in pre-processing
message to sentences replace URLs add
spaces remove useless spaces some of
them I have taken from the excellent
fast AI course pre-processing library so
you can have a look there as well we
will talk about it later for now we're
just going to remove URLs swap them with
URL tag using regular expression
matching of markdown URLs and then we're
going to also chunk it into sentences so
going to discover entities later in that
in that text and we want to enter have
entities that appeared in a sentence and
then discover what's the sentiment of
that sentence and that's just like a
basic use case you know very simplistic
approach to sentiment everybody you know
how you can like express sentiment in
one number or say it's good or bad so we
will get will get to that and but that's
basic premise I think it's robust enough
to try something but also basic enough
to improve which I hope you will do when
you go home
cool so import pre-processing there we
go
and I want to do I have the MSG and I
need to do and Q dot read message data
and now I just have the content and I
can see the text is in hello sorry
statics is in text so that's how I need
to get it so I need to go to here and do
exactly that
q reading message data and also get the
text only pre-processing the replace
URLs just one thing text you can see
type annotations at work text this is a
string and it returns the string it's
just a hint unless you use my PI or some
other type checker so msg text and then
i want to split sentences
right again takes text and also I want
to accept only synthesis of a minimum
character length that's an optional
parameter it's fine for me but feel free
to change it to minus one no just feel
free to change it if you want and then
return sentences so I'm declaring this
and maybe let me try this function
process message msg yes
there's no sentences there what is the
new how am I not relaxed and when it
relaxed process message just one
sentence seems to work I can yeah it
works so process message I'm going back
to my loop where I'm listening process
message post and and then it's just
printed
hello I am relaxed why I you know not
convinced I should make that a string
okay works I've got a list of three
different sentences
so let's now four sentence in it's
called sentences for s in sentences
reddit publish channel name processed MQ
let me break the line MQ serialized
message data yes that's it
actually I don't need to do that because
anyway it's going to be just one string
so I don't need the json serialization
in this case but let's do it anyway just
for safety in case you change it oh why
don't we use TQM
so now as I broke this loop I need to
resupply the first cell and I can run it
again I have my nice progress bar
my first progress bar not too many
people commenting on stocks so I hope if
you chose a different subreddit it's
more active we've got a consumer and we
were processing messages and I could
paste the URL actually maybe that let's
just paste this URL
you see it got replaced with the token
URLs are not too fun to party I mean
they can contain value but you want to
have a strategy for them right otherwise
it's just lots of slashes and columns
and you don't want that great so I'm
happy we are moving fast step 3 so bring
your own model I'm very glad that the
conference organizers were really clever
and they've done the next talk I don't
know if Jeff and Susan are here but I
think everybody named writes their neck
they're giving the next presentation in
the same room so if you want to have a
menagerie of models comforter talk I
hope it's good I actually don't know
them but I hope it's great and the
assumption here is that you have a model
that you developed it's already doing
its job it's doing it well it's signed
off by important executives wearing
suits and ties and it's ready to use so
we're not going to you know do any we're
just assuming that it's a ready model so
let's go to the directory step 3
and here I have prepared two things if
you have prepared for the workshop you
might have used my hockey back script so
with this this this uses Google Drive
and Google Drive requires you to get a
cookie before you download the big file
it's a 300 megabyte file so let's do
distributed denial-of-service and Google
Drive and download this fast day I
trained model right now launch it I will
talk and I hope I hope it downloads in
time if it doesn't download in time what
you need to do is launch terminal and do
step 3 and then Sh
download it's going to download this
model or or open the sentiment notebook
and hit this this line over here cool
but we have a fallback so don't worry if
it doesn't work it will work at home
let's close it for now right
suppose this terminal - I can close my
Redis window - because the container
works just to keep it less confusing so
next step is we want to use the
excellent Spacey package there was just
Spacey IRL hosted in Berlin I encourage
you to follow the contributors who
created Spacey they're excellent
engineers and also very good business
people and very generous they've made
this very widely use NLP solution called
Spacey if I'm sure many of you are
familiar with it if you look at Spacey
if you look at the source code it
contains beautiful things such as Python
objects that have like attributes that
are in C memory so that dramatically
improves processing speed and it's just
a great thing to learn from and also to
use for NLP so we're going to use a
basic small model it just weighs ten
megabytes its trained in English that's
how you download it I already had it how
how would you know import Spacey and
let's load this model if you swap sm for
md you're going to get a larger but more
of a bust model and then LG as well and
you can go in google their full
capabilities and let's try the NLP apply
this model on actually the NLP object
creates like text x runs a pipeline of
things on it and produces an object that
has properties that have different
meaningful things so i'm typing this
message through an LP and I'm creating
this talk object and I can do type dog
it's a spacey dog the pipeline that I
applied so it's the tagger dependency
parser so part of speech tagger
dependency parser and entity recognizer
and
there's more but those are already great
what we were after here is entities and
I have some entities perhaps at the
level that is more granular than I
wanted I could train in my own model
that is trained on tag data what I
really care about so sequence tagging
also another beautiful thing that is
interesting here is long chunks that's a
generator so I need to do a list yeah so
it's there's actually non chunks so
might be interesting for you to and if I
do here's the Jupiter trick I can see
everything is got printed out I can see
everything that starts with a see that
it's got printed out did you know that
who do that all right
made my day when I find it out okay cool
so let's add it as a new step to the
pipeline import and queue subscribe to
processed and let's listen in print
sentence break let's test it those
sentences coming
redditors are sleeping hello
there's another one I am relaxed I only
like convinced and I'm waiting for
another one let's go with by default
it's going to pipe this so what I want
to do now is just use what I've done
here dog equals NLP sentence and this
equals no and what you want to be
careful about is that the elements of
this list will be spacey span objects
those are look like strings taste like
strings you would think there are
strings but their span objects and if
you want adjacency realized you're gonna
have an error unless you use what I've
done here so use the space a special
encoder that will detect those magic
span objects and turn them into strings
so if you import MQ from here you're
safe okay so let's say
well let's publish it output or let's
call it like this output dick and now
confusing and sore entities what am i
doing okay
our our publish to channel NER we're
creating our third channel what's nice
about it you don't NER once and you can
like subscribe multiple models to it and
have them run in parallel compare the
results lock this stuff it's pretty
sweet once you have a system right and
it's easy to extend the modular module
or problem publish this and MQ
serialized message data output o TQ liam
yes
got it there's no entities in that
sentence pigs are not entities let's
move on to the sentiment over hitting
halftime would you like to ask any
questions at this point I'm excited I
that probably means that things are
clear enough and you can also catch me
later
buy me beers and I'll answer it just
kidding just chat now this probably can
fail for you but it will will not fail
when you try it hard enough and with
good internet connection but um that's
like that's also where kondeh
environments and doctor files are so
useful because when you advance to more
complicated models those usually have
the dependencies both on many packages
and concrete versions of those packages
and if you change a version by one step
who knows maybe part of the API changed
and it's not reproducible enough I mean
it's your code doesn't work anymore and
you put it so you share it it's from
someone doesn't work for them you put it
in production doesn't work so what you
want to do is use those things and save
yourself time don't waste time
configuring things don't waste time
doing things that are not meaningful in
the long run so let's use let's use
environments docker and and so forth we
need faster I version exactly this and
it's an excellent wonderful course
prepared by Jeremy Howard and Rochelle
Thomas they are and Sylvain Google they
are out of San Francisco I believe and
they've just made a very accessible
course to learn about the power of
neural nets it's just some calculus and
it's not not really that that you know
sophisticated and it's very creative use
of this math but it's like not that you
have to learn a bunch of things you just
need to learn a few things and try them
and use them so I highly encourage you
as a matter of fact we should probably
catch up about this who's using who's
heard of fast the eye nice yeah
great half of you great amazing who's
done fast there all right good
are you happy about it did you like it
yeah do you use it okay yeah cool great
so we're gonna use it now
if it works if did you did the model
download for you oh okay so this is
taken from lesson three trained on IMDB
movie reviews just two classes positive
or negative because that's where you can
be right thank you people are either one
bucket around another skinny
so you can download it like this here I
won't try it I'll just go and copy it
from my super-secret directory
[Music]
not Sydney okay so now I have this here
did you know that you can execute shell
commands in Jupiter with exclamation
mark so that's we're gonna do on power
this model depends on I mean I need to
recreate it so I'm going to rename the
directory I have a model directory now
I'm loading this loading the data it's
like they have an object called data
bunch it helps with training serving
batches have data also holding
information about classes so forth and
there's a learner a learner is a clever
object that takes a model and a data and
lets you find things like optimal
learning rate and which is one of the
hyper parameters and then also run
different schedules and cycles of
learning that they have really iterated
on they actually competed on speed of
like they wanted to train and an
architecture on a data on known data I
think was C far or one of the other
image data sets and they were competing
for speed who reaches certain accuracy
first and they were winning with much
bigger and situation like they went one
with a googol submission and just a
group of independent people just like
we're here so it's pretty amazing this
library and the course itself so just
going to initialize it load the model
put it PI touch it spiders under the
hood so by touch you can like set the
model into evaluation mode so to remove
all the dropout layers and and so forth
and make it and make it not calculate
the gradients just sort of execute
faster so I have an example negative
message which says I don't know I keep
focusing on negative things because and
I want to predict the sentiment and it's
a negative sentiment 91 percent sure 92%
and
and of course I love this workshop right
and then it's positive
96% sure so I've wrote everything a
little helper here which is going to
just run it for us and keep the score in
the class and return it so we can pass
it further down the pipe and let's try
again yeah this is just the output so
this category is a special type and then
this is a PI torch tensor of dimension 1
and PI thirds tensor dimension 2 so I
don't want to you know get bogged down
so utilizing this into a Redis format
I'll just subscribe to named entity
recognition import my mq if you didn't
work for you if didn't download you can
use this as a placeholder not you know
stop yourself from continuing on with
the workshop it will just provide a very
smart prediction I trained it on lots of
date let's let's have a look
print data and break
oh no I wanted to pipe
yes okay no entities by no affiliation
with John Travolta John Travolta so we
have one entity here as a matter of fact
let me go back to NER and and only pass
the message if there is an entity in it
so if Len and it's greater than zero and
I need to stop this pipe Rhys absque
ribe relaunch and now I will not see
messages coming through that yeah that
don't that didn't come through and now
if I send the one with John Travolta
again it just sent me one sentence so
just to save yourself reading logs right
so let's do a sprint
so sentiment and score equals predict
sentiment out of data sentence right
okay so it's very negative but it works
so we can now let's keep it let's say
our output is then oh let's let's pipe
it for separate identity separate
entities so for e in entities
right
and our publish ready I'm gonna call the
final channel ready because I'm assuming
that I'm not doing anything more in this
system at this point I will do more I
mean please come up with ideas yeah I'm
happy you know really happy to hear your
thoughts and ideas later on and how you
want to extend it or what do you want to
do because yeah you can add more things
you can add more models you have you can
learn from the next speakers about
different models you can use and yeah
make it work so MQ serialize output
don't break and let's do you know this
won't work tickety
who mystic over there okay so now we
have four components living in my lab
it's a very professional setting right I
can share these with anybody just take
my lab no it's it's not reproducible
right and I'm importing I have the same
mq file in every directory that's lame
why don't I have it you know I don't I
have my features and functionality is
bundled so that I can access the same
code from many places so that's what
we're going to talk about next and
that's also what I think one of my
parallel speakers is covering so if you
are interested in that more probably you
can watch this video let me just go here
yeah those are the links to the faster I
and Spacey you should definitely check
it check both out probably more of you
know Spacey than fast there but check
both out and the first day I just
published an LP course - so cool so step
four moving beyond my lab some good
books to recommend you know this
excellent publishing series it's a it's
sarcasm and it's I think it's funny
that's why I added it here and yeah
basically a funny way of it's like a
Dilbert for for real occurrences in the
office right sometimes the opened over
and you're like oh it's so real so
really it hurts so one of the phrases
that works in my machine
right figure it out no you want to make
it easy for people to use your stuff
because that really matters that that
will help you build meaningful
relationships with people build you know
learn from people have people appreciate
your work
many a time I see a very very brilliant
very experienced and knowledgeable
people who who basically would achieve
so much more if they just took one extra
step and share their work or get more
recognition you know if you deal with
executives they they don't know the
different intricacies of the model for
them it's just okay he knows and he's
good we're you know paying him enough to
or her ladies just as encouraged to
participate I think it's very nice that
the code of conduct and enforces that
enforces invites and celebrates you know
participation from everybody who wants
and also they've been kind enough to my
wife is here and they they have free
childcare it's I think it's really
wonderful and we feel much you know the
idea I just feel great that they can be
here and I think it's wonderful so I
actually I want to give an applause and
special so but going back to my are my
jokes funny you know import error just
don't move the files if I move the mq
just one directory up I can't afford it
anymore you don't want that so we're
gonna go deal with that by bundling and
let me just go back to the lab real
quick go to step four and on the on the
note of the consumer let me use an
example so this is a module just as you
do people install TQ DM or pip install
pandas you can go to the repo and see
the structure but basically I have my
module like all my code base here so
what I have here is is this actually let
me go to the code editor so I use vs
code and make it very large perhaps too
large
and goto bundling and yeah I can
advocate ignore and list all the Python
things I don't want to check out check
in also my configuration files big files
like the model my data set I can do a
Conda environment but the most important
thing of making it a Python like a pip
installable situation well we always
have a readme is to have set up the PI
and have a look and feel free to
critique this here example but
essentially you have this function here
which is set up you can specify version
name author and when you when you create
a package with this oops
you are ready to publish it to pip and
other people can use it you can publish
it to your own pip and people who you
know can use it people can build it from
a good path not only for from a wheel so
when you when you build it it becomes a
wheel and you don't need and then your
consumers don't need to build it so just
some like basic stuff but it's really
really useful and goes a long way in
making making it easy for others to
consume your work to use your work so
what I want to use here today is things
I actually learned from my colleague
here who is also me how conveniently if
you want to create that you know
sometimes you have these nice neat
modules that like create console command
like Alice's command line Isis that you
can like launch like for example one of
yeah I don't know like you do I say my
NLP do some something the there is a way
to make that happen
here instead of PI you just need a
keyword entry points console scripts and
then you can create a name of the alias
and point to what needs to get executed
and then you can launch it so let me
just maybe do
step four yes yeah
so if I do pip in that consumer with
this commented out
let me save processing successfully
built okay successfully installed so now
I can go to ipython or Python and do
from reddit consumer imports something
that I want but if I do if I uncomment
this and install again then I can do
this here ready to consumer and it lives
in my environment so I can yeah there's
a there's a bug somewhere in there but
we're gonna get to the bottom of this
mostly because I intend to showcase
something more here cool so let's go to
consumer and what you see here is just
double underscore it done there in it
and then you can have main and you can
have your pieces of code and you can
like import from these paths just like
you do from scikit-learn dot optimizers
in import this with that you can build
your own code so let's go to main and
here's another thing that I want to
showcase which I also learned from my
great colleague here who is convenien
ami how is fire so let's go import fire
I don't know if you have any experience
doing like command-line enter interfaces
in Python and you know some people use
art parts or just like Ross's arc V or
yeah say good click yeah
so some of them are like really verbose
and you have to write a lot of
boilerplate so fire is an easy one it
just fires a method or about you getting
the fire variable but it fires a class
in my case and this it's a stream
consumer and yeah what I have here is
def main
and I want to do fire dot fire and then
string consumer that's it so if I pay
per install with - e-type installed an
editable model and yeah so fire prints
my usage for me automatically if I had a
doc string it would print the doc string
the set of PI points to main module dot
done the remain and then method main our
function main so this then fires the
stream consumer and if I do
STD out yeah
it's gonna print errors to my studio
what's it gonna do is do the Redis
message a reddit message consumption and
printed in interest yeah but that's how
you create a bundle
you just need like the init which is
empty and you need your code which you
can move your code from your notebook or
from your prototype or from your
scattered directory you can assign it
versions there's there's modules that
make versioning easier so highly
recommend this way of working once you
have figured out like your approach to
bundle it up and version it very useful
for sharing very useful for keeping
track of stuff very highly recommended
okay so that's beyond my lab and then
step five this will be hopefully easy do
you have the telegram API key who's got
one okay if you don't you might want to
just like Google telegram bot father and
get one very quickly it's super fast you
just say slash start answer three
questions and you get the API key so
that's another thing that I find
staggering how how little sharing goes
such a long way when you're in a company
and you make people make it easy for
people to use your you're like what you
build you build a web app you it may you
make it look a little bit beautiful very
beautiful depending on how skilled you
are and jsr and front-end design or but
you can like start a bootstrap webpage
with some GS and serve your your stuff
through an API and people in your office
you know people who don't have any
knowledge of Python just like use Excel
they they can use your predictions they
can use your visualizations and its
really impressively they start to you
know know what you're doing
trust what you're doing and that gives
you a lot of ability to then I go to
them and share with and things that
improve the
day that you know make their work easier
so I really highly encourage you to
think how can I make my contribution to
my company more accessible right it
really it will just dramatically improve
the velocity of your career progression
or whatever you're doing it's it's it's
really really important and and yeah and
this you know it's in this day and age
of hashtag portfolio is the new diploma
it's a it's when you build things like I
said you know technology's come up so
quickly that in the end in five years no
one's gonna care that you knew the
kubernetes of 2018 you know what they
will care about is what you did with it
what you built with it and that that
stays that's impressive
so ship stuff so once you're here let me
let me just show you so what this does
it hides the dot end file so I'm going
to go to the code editor again I'm in my
native directory I have my dot end file
one one step higher so you have it an
example what you need is your telegram
key for now and if you have your
telegram key you paste it here this long
thing then you will be able to do echo
bot so either run it in the console or
run it here yep start polling and I'm
going to from my phone I can also do it
from the computer but I'll do it from my
phone find my bot and say hi
now I sent it to a channel let me say hi
yeah so
you probably can see because it's only
fun but I have it tell told me what is
my ID but if I open it here well I can
make it bigger right so hi who are you
you know it's a echo but if you run it
it starts polling the book that you
created for new messages and it's going
it's you can look it up what's in the
code but it will just echo what you like
your hello and tell you your ID so copy
that ID don't copy my ID copy that ID
and and place it in my telegram number
you'll be able to send messages to
yourself with the second script let's
have a look here what's inside so the
API that powers this is a i/o Graham
it's a synchronous and it's got like a
really nice rich API when you want to
enhance it you'll see that there's
options for sending rich content like
videos photos sound so you can even
write write a thing that you know takes
a soundbite and write your own searches
are more you know just very simple send
it to your but it does I think it also
does polls you can set up stripe with it
so it's this why I chose it too because
it's it enables many things and it's
accessible it's a free works really
quick I think the owner made made a lot
of money on a Russian version of
Facebook like hundreds of millions and
and now it doesn't care to make that
much more apparently on this one at
least and it's it's a great product
which is free so there's there's a
dispatcher of a bot message handler and
just an echo takes any message you can
write different handlers for different
types of messages with regular
expressions with content types with
posters of stuff so yeah just look at
we don't have that much time to cover it
but this is just move quickly and I hope
you've added your telegram number I'm
going to shut down this situation and
just publish so the publisher look more
complicated but it listens to the Redis
messages and then for every message in
the channel here it's the channel name
is ready uses fire this publisher
essentially does an async listen and
then push push update and it's supposed
to push it to the channel that I
specified in telegram so for me is this
channel here and let me pipe a message
with John Travolta and let me see if I
know it didn't come through sentiment Oh
entities is not defined okay so that's a
that's actually yeah that's what it is
I used the variable but it's a key word
in this dict so let's try again yep okay
came through telegram came through my
app came through you can apply nice
formatting but yeah I got someone said
something negative about John Travolta I
gotta do something you know I can drop
okay what I'm doing and go out there and
save the world but in the end like I say
I had this idea like you know when you
invest it said that dollar cost
averaging is a smart idea because
instead of buying everything you want
like I have a thousand pounds for
example I want to put a set aside for my
future and I can buy a thousand pounds
worth of Microsoft stock today and I am
tied to this price but if I spread out
the buying overtime then over a month
let's say then I'll I'll buy for the
average price of that month so that kind
of brings me some security you know if
there's a crash because trade talks with
China we're going well and not going
well anymore or whatever so for example
if you have a company that you like and
you trust in it and there's there's like
a massive downfall one day maybe you
want to buy on that day you know because
you don't care you and you're in it for
the long run so that's one use case that
I had in mind yeah just get creative and
see what you can do and I hope it's
useful for you and you can write some
nice formatting you can add another
module for formatting but without
further ado let's let's keep this
running
it's a beautiful lab of five notebooks
and one script so it's not very big if I
want to run it in the cloud because hey
you know I do this I shut down my
computer and it'll be and my amazing
service is not serving me anymore
so what what I want to do is I want to
orchestrate this which leads us to slide
about orchestration so this is also
useful yeah I said making friends with
the operations team that's also massive
in businesses when you're like when you
have your code and you sell it to ops
and if you have the best of luck the the
Ops guys are like excited to help you
but I I wish to work with such people
and sometimes the enthusiasm is maybe
lower on their side and if something
that you proposed doesn't work
immediately like that then they come to
you and say why this isn't work there's
a bug or error and they say oh there was
an error and like it's your fault so you
want to kind of be on good terms with
them also protect yourself from
stressful events so as as if you package
stuff well this is a great investment
you know for your team for yourself for
your for the things you spend your time
on so what we're gonna do we're going to
use docker and dock and compose I hope
you've installed them if not do it at
home
try it at home it's really nice and you
can configure really sophisticated
setups quickly so let me go to the lab
go to the last step and open here is
your doctor compost that's what it looks
like it's a yam oh and it tells me like
just I'm I'm saying like just abstractly
saying what I want in my system those
are the services I want I want to read
consumer I want to read this to serve as
the message queue back-end
I want a processor probably another
processor
I've actually bundled the - NOP things
into one because I wanted to make it
quicker the demo but ideally they should
be the same disentangle and so I want
these things and I want the telegram
publisher and they they have a network
they're sharing and subvolumes and yeah
it's it's really easy I let's say I I
want to okay I want to build a docker
image which is contained in the docker
file in reddit consumer so let me go in
the read consumer click the docker file
it's gonna take mini Condor update Conda
create copy the environment from my
directory into the virtual machine
create the environment then activate it
these are some any things that just make
the conductive aide not not trigger
errors and then finally copy the content
of my working directory into app install
it and then run it that's all there is
so and and you can like have all of this
you can just share it put it on the VM
put it in the cloud put it like probably
on some app server - you can have the
image and just like save it this was the
version that I developed them that day
and I can just take it run it I don't
need to have any like it just ready like
already made me mento
by the way docker builds this image
sequentially and it checkpoints on each
step so there is logic in the madness
you see the copy app is only at the end
because that lets me iterate quickly and
not wait the ages that you will have to
wait when you do darker build for the
first time it's going to do the Conda
environment building downloading pandas
downloading this downloading that once
you do it one time and you have the
image cache each time you change some
code in your in your code base it's just
going to copy or copies so start from
911 and run much quicker so that's
that's what's happening underneath
finally yeah so I want it to be failsafe
so it fails somehow I wanted to restart
I want the container name of this image
that it so this recipe builds a
container named talker consumer and the
image tag is also sorry Betty consumer
review consumer it depends on Reddy's DB
so if it starts it needs to starts after
it is to be it uses the shared network
back-end and then it has an environment
variable Redis DB for Redis URL just so
that all the services know what is DB
comes from here it's just like tells you
okay I'm not looking at localhost I'm
looking at another URL and this is the
entry point command so I want to read it
from the Shelf reddit consumer put it on
Redis on to channel comments then
finally read is DB so ready alpine very
small image back and expose this port
map the ports if I want to also connect
to it from localhost and this is an
exercise we can do together now so let's
uncomment this container name message
sir you can be naughty and call it
something else
oh that's actually in the next line that
links some other links it needs to link
to release dB
and then it depends on that is DB has
the same environment situation as here
and then back-end Network entry point in
bash yep it's gonna it's gonna do it
save it
finding the telegram publisher you can
also see like go into here and see how
that differs from Step five is just the
same publisher but has an Onan file in
there has a docker file downloads the
builds environment
cool so now you know the I hope the
curse of live demos doesn't get me but
let me start a new shell teeny-tiny
shell and do kondeh activate and then CD
okay see in step six and all you need to
do at this point is just to docker
compose up
[Music]
external connectivity okay so port is
already allocated I already have my
other red is going so what I need to do
is go back to step one look at what I
have here maybe even better
there is a UI called kite Matic I have
these here things going and let me stop
and remove my delicious reddit so I've
used it I could also just do copy this
in the docker stop sorry
and then docker RM but you know I I like
nice you wise docker compose up done yes
so all my services are started and I
should be receiving a stream of messages
to my telegram but I'm not
so let me pipe a pipe something
let me see
maybe it's the network let me try to to
do here a console
[Music]
yep
zero
no I'm actually I'm getting some
messages by data London
there's someone someone copy my ID no
that's fine
I guess I'll forgive you and we're 80
minutes in so on that note let me just
yeah look we've we've done it it
actually worked out the curse
didn't get me maybe it's like people and
on our stocks are slow to to write
messages but let me go to conclusion
slides and we've done so many services
so consuming message queue
pre-processing and named entity
recognition sentiment classification
bundled about orchestrated the services
and yeah I think we we covered a lot so
I hope it was accessible I hope it was
easy to grasp as long as you tried it
that's great and you know it's it's the
intention is that it feels that like oh
it's my knowledge I know how to do it
you don't need to know the details but
you can like go learn about the details
it's not none of this was you know very
high high difficulty but it's good to
see how all these things come together
and make a solution easier to use and
more accessible get you recognize you
can you know build a machine learning
models serve it easily through a mobile
app how many times you want to do hot
dog not hot dog but you didn't have an
ape like you know a framework to send
your mobile phone pictures right so now
you can do it with telegram yeah I think
about all the time I wake up it's like
is this a hot dog or not yeah I gotta
work on my jokes yeah so if you have
ideas to make the system better use them
they're probably great ideas this is far
from perfect but as every true
perfectionist knows there is no reaching
perfection so yeah think about what you
can contribute think about what you can
do to to build your portfolio and yeah
think of the one thing that you learned
today
that you think really was the most
valuable for you the biggest thing that
you can take and use after this
conference you're gonna see a lot of
cool stuff at this conference probably
come up I know usually I come up with a
big head and try to remember everything
but it's only what you act on that that
in the end that matters because this
knowledge will be updated updated
updated changed people will come up with
new stuff yeah so tell me what did you
like most my voice no so someone likes
something yeah yeah please go ahead
appreciate it great thanks I think so
too I think that was like the core
intention so I'm really happy you say
that thank you cool yeah
share your work please stay in touch
with me if you do something great share
and I'll share it further further
yeah really think of like what you can
contribute because people really want to
see what you build
people really care and you know that's a
great way to showcase what your
initiative your creativity just a fun to
write it's like like a hobby project or
you can do something with your you know
younger sister younger brother get them
excited about coding yeah and write a
blog post if you want that's another
nice thing to do so many times people
like there is this kind of way of
development Stack Overflow driven
development where you just like look for
solutions so many times people find your
blog post when they were looking for
something and it's really helpful how
many times have you stock overflow I use
it all the time I I don't pretend to
have a you know library of a brain I I
know many things but I can remember all
of them because I wouldn't have the RAM
to to have you know the actionable
things so write a blog post people will
appreciate it give yourself a chance and
yeah if you have any questions feel free
to ask if you also like reach me on
slack on PI data slack get to meet one
another as years next to each other yeah
thank you
[Applause]